on a reckless driver from earlier today
bloomington 38th
last scene southbound boarding for red
lights and speeding
it's only at 7 55. and just mix the
states in the area in your call
they're witnessing a physical domestic
at the intersection involving a black
male gray flannel blue jeans and black
shoes
it's been a year since the murder of
george floyd by a white police officer
in minneapolis
right back where it began ground zero
about 20 yards for me is where that man
lost his life
over the past 12 months the never-ending
struggle against racism and inequality
has intensified we spent a lot of days
here
a lot of time here
that's what it feels like coming home
once again there is talk of progress but
the question remains
will the death of george floyd really
bring the changes
that can guarantee justice for black
america
like how important is this how important
is this
we're heading into
the neighborhood where we spent most of
our childhood
we actually lived right here in this
building
on the door on the right side
we spent many many years here the
building
was just open and you could kind of pull
up and park right here
we were very close we we did you know
everything together
was really fun i have a lot of good
memories
being here
george floyd grew up in the third ward
district of houston texas
his mother lucernia had moved there from
north carolina in the 1970s
to find work and throughout his life
the two remained close she was very
proud of him
he was had many talents and he was very
good at a lot of things that he did so
she had a lot of reasons to be to be
proud of him
one year on from her cousin's murder
tara now dedicates her life to
campaigning in his name
and reminding the world of the man who
inspired a global movement
wow george he
i don't know he was just
how do you describe it he just had this
spirit that just kind of drew people to
him he was just like a magnet that way
people were just naturally drawn to him
because of how big his
you know personality and his his heart
was
george grew up in a low-income family in
bad housing with few prospects
and like millions of black americans
contact with the police was a daily
experience
there was always the presence of the
police always made everybody feel
uncomfortable
back in those times because
obviously a lot of people
were afraid you know there were people
who were doing bad things but even the
people who weren't necessarily doing bad
things were treated the same
but during most of his teens george
managed to stay out of trouble
he was a brilliant natural athlete and
is remembered today for his sporting
ability
when i lived next door to george he was
in high school at yanks he was playing
football yesterday
scholarship that's right and was getting
ready to get on our graduation
do his thing man and the whole the whole
community was just so happy
he always bring joy to this to this
neighborhood
but in the late 1990s george's life
changed his friends say he fell in with
the wrong crowd
and he was arrested a total of nine
times in a 10-year period
like so many black men from a similar
background
it was the start of a cycle that would
prove difficult
to break the system is structured in a
way that makes it
much more likely that a black person and
particularly a black man
will come into contact with a police
officer
who is the first entry point into the
criminal justice system and
wind up in a cycle of recidivism
this says eroded our community in many
respects it has impacted our families it
has impacted
the next generation of young people who
are growing up
without their loved ones in the home due
to this system of mass incarceration
after his last prison sentence in texas
george made his way
north to minneapolis
he lived there for six years working a
variety of jobs including a security
guard and a truck driver
and throughout that time he kept in
touch with his mother
just a phone call from him would just
light up her entire day
like um after he moved to minneapolis
and you know she could go on
for hours about a ten minute call that
she had with him
um it was just amazing how he had that
effect on her the evening of the 25th of
may last year
george went out to buy a pack of
cigarettes
the weather was good sun was shining um
and my co-workers were all laughing and
joking it was a normal day for me just
coming in to get something to drink and
noticed that there was a couple police
cars
on the corner he came in to get his
phone fixed and also some cigarettes
gave me a fake 20. my manager asked me
to go to the car
asked him to come inside and eventually
the police were called
i've seen you know two officers out
there and uh
and i seen george floyd in a situation
everyone watching um and everyone
yelling at the police officers
right now bro and just watching
everything kind of unfold
knowing that we couldn't do anything
everything was slow motion for me the
panting and
you know
the stress that george was in you know
it felt like
that he was you know struggling the
recording of the last minutes
of george's life is haunting
harrowing and horrific
just kidding
what do you want i can't breathe please
i don't think i've watched that
video at full length i've seen
bits and pieces my stomach my neck
everything
there's water or something
hearing his voice was enough
hearing his moans and his pleas
um was
very hard because this is a voice i've
known my whole life
um i recognized it and i knew it was him
even though i didn't want to believe it
i knew it was him hey
you [ __ ] stopping his breathing right
there bro
bro he's not even [ __ ] moving get off
of his [ __ ] neck bro
get off of his neck
uh when i was pacing up and down the
sidewalk with my hands on my head i was
just
pretty much wishing i could go back in
time and reverse everything
at that time i felt like i witnessed a
murder
quite lately could not believe what was
happening right in front of my eyes
i'd never seen anything like it
after nine minutes and 29 seconds of
being restrained
george floyd is later pronounced dead
killed by a white police officer called
derek chovin
but unlike many acts of police brutality
george floyd's murder was recorded
and when the video was released the city
went up in flames we were ready to
destroy everything
we were ready to destroy everything and
rightfully so we watched someone get
killed by the police in real time
and minneapolis was just the beginning
for black americans the murder of george
floyd was the latest in a long line of
atrocities
committed by police officers it's just
hard to watch a human being
be killed so slow and so cruel
this is status quo for what has gone on
in this country for so long so
it wasn't anything out of the ordinary
except
that there was overwhelming evidence
that what transpired was murder
i was like oh my god this has happened
again
when i eventually did get to watch
some of the video i really wasn't able
to watch it all it was just it was too
painful
to actually see the life
sucked out of a human being
and to analyze how another human being a
police officer
in this case could lose his humanity
and be so barbaric
in the days that followed his fellow
citizens came to pay their respects
and by night they took to the streets
to vend their fury
fires riots burning
anger despair helplessness
all of those words were what minneapolis
was feeling
we witnessed the murder
when we left george floyd square that
night after curfew
we literally got to lake street and
all this all this was on fire
39 year old michael wilson is a local dj
this is the the infamous precinct that
derek chauvin worked in
oh man i know that was you
he is the son of a police officer and
describes himself as a patriot who loves
his country
hey you know what i've never told you
this taco means tactical awareness of
community organizing
oh wow that's all that's meant the whole
time but the day
george died changed his life forever
they left us with no other options if
you look down the the trail of history
we've tried protests we've tried
legislation we've tried to ask him
questions we've tried
civility we were just tired of telling
anytime we tried it we're always we we
were always told as black people
that no that's the wrong way to do it
over the next few days as news of
george's death in police custody spread
across the nation
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets
in protests that lasted for weeks
the killing of george floyd had touched
something very deep
in the psyche of black americans it was
seen as no different from the countless
other crimes committed against them
since the nation was founded
a man was lynched the man was lynched
it wasn't any different than a lot of
other
you know senseless murders of black
people at the hands of police
this one was just caught on tape and
this one wasn't a bullet it was an e
but it it's the same story over and over
again
for many the memories of lynch mobs are
all
too recent my late dad would have seen
a lynching and he did as a little boy
they used to have atrocity what we would
now call atrocity
postcards which showed the lynching
and they would have them in the county
store when you went and bought food and
it would be on the counter
and they traded them and there'd be
little kids looking to turn toward the
camera smiling while this body
is hanging from a tree
our nation was founded as a white
supremacist project
and every government entity was created
to enforce white supremacy
and that legacy still has
tentacles that reach into our society
and they're demonstrated through racial
disparities
in every aspect of life
by the 1960s black america had
had enough we are ready now to march on
ballot box
across the nation millions of men and
women started to demand equality in
schooling
housing and job opportunities and an end
to segregation and brutality
and throughout the civil rights movement
one man embodied the hopes and dreams
of a generation now is the time to make
real the promises of democracy now is a
time
to transform the bleak and desolate
midnight
of man's inhumanity to man into a
glowing daybreak of freedom and justice
my father would always do
things in a non-violent way he used the
philosophy of non-violence to bring
about
change he was a bridge builder
he wanted to see freedom justice and
equality
exist for all humankind but justice and
equality for all
was not what many white americans wanted
to hear
oh
and then in 1968 one evening in memphis
tennessee
racist white america hit back
here's a man who is engaged in
non-violence trying to transform and
change
our society and then you go out and kill
him
and people just didn't know what to do
the violent death of dr martin luther
king was a mortal blow to the civil
rights movement
and brought to a halt his dream of
uniting america
against racial injustice
52 years later it has taken the killing
of another black man to bring millions
of americans together
many of them marching under the banner
of a movement that is again
calling for transformation in society
like any
organization black lives matter is is
complicated
i don't believe that the agenda of the
founders was uh
ever intended to to be radical
it was progressive and had they not been
doing what they're doing
we may not be at this level of
consciousness
he's
it's time to call it out for what it is
i call these police departments the klu
klux klan with badges on
it's time for us to stand up in george's
name
and say get your knee off our necks
condemned by its political opponents as
too extreme
its supporters see it as continuing the
work that began with the civil rights
movement
i would question anyone that claims that
seeking to be treated as a human being
is radical that is simply
all that the movement is asking for
treat people
with dignity stop abusing and
criminalizing
black people stop killing black people
what is radical to me is the fact that
we have allowed police to beat people
to kill people to see it on camera and
for them to literally be able to get
away
with murder that's radical seeking
our right to breathe
and live the quality of life that we
deserve
is not radical but it is necessary
four days after george's death in police
custody
officer derek chauvin was arrested and
then charged with third degree murder
but history has shown that justice for
his victim
is by no means a foregone conclusion
we've seen this happen before and
there's been video before
and you know police officers still were
not
charged or convicted in those cases so
we know that
there's no guarantee that we're going to
get what we're looking for
so we feel a little anxious you have
you're in a position where you're going
to trust
the criminal justice system that has
failed you before
please right hand please do you swear or
affirm that you will be attentive
during this trial and follow the
instructions of the court
so that you may reach a fair and just
verdict
derek chervin's trial opened in
minneapolis on the 29th of march
the eyes of the world were focused on
this crucial moment in american criminal
history
chauvin faced some of the most serious
charges ever to be laid against a police
officer
while on duty mr derrick shaman
betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no legs and gentlemen
until the very life
were squeezed out of them
it was up to the state prosecutors to
prove that the force he used was
unreasonable
under the circumstances continue to
apply for many
reliving those agonizing last minutes of
george's life
was deeply traumatic
the trial lasted for three weeks and on
april 20th
the jury was ready with a verdict all
right for the journey
i was literally shaking when i got the
call because
we didn't expect to get a verdict that
soon please be seated
i remember just saying oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
because here it is there's all this
buildup we the jury in the above
entitled matter has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
verdict count two either during the
above entitled matter as to count
two third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter as to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty
relief absolutely
i thought it was uh the right decision
the only twelve i respect is them twelve
jurors
i'm free he's not i wasn't surprised
when
the jury came back with a guilty verdict
in such amount of time
and these your verdicts
i find that uh the verdict says red
reflect the will of the jury and will be
filed accordingly
it was just a tremendous it was more of
a relief
it's hard to celebrate anything
that is so unfortunate or to be in a
celebratory mode
even for someone who did something wrong
bail is revoked bond is discharged and
the defendant is remanded to the custody
of the hannibal county sheriff
but i don't think we can yet evaluate
whether this means
there's going to be wholesale changes
because there were so many cases that
have occurred prior to this one
where no one has been convicted for
those
for those charges
my body wouldn't let me celebrate it
like i celebrated for maybe five seconds
in my head and then i went right over to
the pitcher
said brother george we're finished here
we got more work to do
but mission accomplished next mission
that's how i felt next mission and the
question remained
why had such a toxic culture been
allowed to fester
for so long before the trial
chauvin's police service record had been
made public
over 19 years he had received 18
misconduct complaints yet had still been
allowed to act as a training officer
those complaints aren't something that
harm
somebody's advancement in law
enforcement but some actually
distinguishes them in a way that that
somebody could become a training agent
after receiving
complaints about unnecessary police
violence right now
it's more dangerous to your law
enforcement career to report racist
misconduct by a colleague
than it is to engage in racist
misconduct
very few officers have broken cover to
discuss the culture of racism
in the force my name is reddit hudson
my first name is r-e-d-d-i-t-t
last name is hudson h-u-d-s-o-n
but this former member of the saint
louis police department
is outspoken in his condemnation you
know some people
kill with impunity look at derek shoving
you know i think derek children is a
piece of [ __ ] you know i say that as a
former officer
who observed what he did to george floyd
and i'm becoming increasingly aware of
his record and i know that there are
other officers out there who take
life or the life of black people just as
lightly as he did
although under no illusions when he
joined the department
he was still shocked at what he found
not only was racism present but it was
often casually accepted and expected
and and so you know you get leadership
that's not responsive in the way that it
should be
to the racism that is exhibited in
within the department
when barack obama won his first election
an historic night in our country one of
my fellow officers
this white guy sent out an email to
multiple officers multiple officers the
email said
i can't believe that i live in a country
full of
lovers with about 20 exclamation points
behind it it was in all caps
his attempts to change the culture from
within proved futile
and eventually he took the decision to
quit
ultimately i decided look i don't want
to be at the front end
of a system that at its foundation is
institutionally racist
since his departure he has continued to
monitor how law enforcement in america
abuses its power
let me see your hands
how many occupants are in the vehicle
what's going on
how many occupants are in your vehicle
it's only myself why are your weapons
drawn what's
going on the door slowly step out
open the door i'm not getting out the
vehicle what's going on
this footage was taken in december 2020
it shows u.s army lieutenant karen
rosario being pulled over in windsor
virginia
you know many times officers ultimately
don't give a damn what the law is
the law is what we say it is out here on
the streets
until i can be held accountable for
whatever i do out
here get out of the car now
i'm serving this country and this is how
i'm treated there's some departments who
are
shown to have wildly disproportionate
stops
of blacks versus other motorists what's
going on
it used to be something crazy like at
100 times the rate
and then they brought it down to
something like 18 times the rate of
white people
and called that a success oh man we're
really doing good we're only stopping
black said 18 times the rate of whites
even though blacks only make up 13 14
percent of the population here
i'm i'm honestly afraid to get out can i
actually let's go get out what's going
on what did i do
get out now i have not committed any
crimes you're being stopped from a
tribal violation you're not cooperating
at this point right now
you're under arrest right traffic you're
being detained okay you're being
detained foreign violation i do not have
to get out the vehicle you haven't even
told me why i'm being stopped
really get
watch it the burning to lieutenant
nazario's face
is caused by pepper spray discharged by
one of the officers
get out of the car now that's [ __ ] up
that's funny get out of the car now sir
just get out the car i'm trying to
breathe
that kind of madness is going to go on
regardless unless there is some penalty
that's painful enough to a department uh
to address the issue
you made this way more difficult it had
to be if you just comply
get out of the car i'm reaching for my
seatbelt fine take your seatbelt off and
get out of the car
the officer who sprayed nazario in the
face has been fired
his partner who ordered the stop is
still serving
such events are by no means isolated
in april in the middle of derrick
shawn's trial
the police pulled over another black man
the stop took place in brooklyn center a
suburb of minneapolis
where george floyd was murdered
in the state of minnesota we have a
significant problem with racial
profiling
it's been well documented yet it has
never been addressed
racial profiling has led to many black
people
being pulled over being harassed being
criminalized
the driver of the vehicle is 20 year old
dante wright
less than a minute after the stop an
officer pulls a sidearm
and dante is shot dead
the brooklyn center police later
describes the killing
as an accident
as i watch the video and listen to the
officer's commands it is my belief that
the officer
had the intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr wright
with a single bullet the officer who
killed dante
is now facing manslaughter charges
being black being poor
being pulled over can be a dead sentence
in the state of minnesota and in many
parts of this country
in the eight years since the black lives
matter movement was formed
dozens more black americans have died at
the hands of the u.s police
at last there is widespread recognition
that this brutality
has to stop
you know i don't even think it's up for
legitimate debate anymore in this
country
whether or not we have a racism issue
with policing in america whether or not
we have a systemic racism issue when it
comes to the foundations of our criminal
justice process
i don't even think it's up for
legitimate debate
the debate may be underway but just
how far is america prepared to go to
bring about the foundational changes
required
for racial justice
george floyd's murder meant that once
again racism in america was under
international scrutiny we
are fighting an institutional systemic
problem that has been allowed to
permeate
since we were brought to these shores
we are fighting wickedness
in high places
although his death was a tragedy there
was hope
that it might not have been in vain
if there is a moment in time
where this momentum
is present it's now
it is now and we can feel it
everybody around us can feel it i don't
even know how to describe it other than
to
know it's a feeling that you know
people are aware and people want to see
change despite that optimism at the time
of his funeral
there remained many obstacles to reform
donald trump was in the white house a
president described by many as the most
divisive in the country's history
and the way he handled the crisis that
swept the nation after george's
murder infuriated millions his response
as a president was [ __ ] [ __ ]
he should have had his ass here in
minneapolis on the flight
in front of the media telling us that
what the officers did was
wrong unjust and unpatriotic
and that fury at donald trump and his
legacy
deepened in january
people were incensed at the soft
treatment of the crowd who stoned
capitol hill
a mob who refused to accept he had lost
the election
it was the biggest display of civic
unrest since the marches over george's
murder
in minneapolis
but the hands-off response by the police
reinforced the sense for black americans
that racism was rooted in the system
comparison january 6 2500 plus people
just started to storm a capital which
was national
no which was federal trespassing
but if we're protesting right we protest
we get
what do we get flash bangs pepper balls
rubber bullets some cases real bullets
they actually killed a police officer
in the process
and yet they were treated as if their
actions were largely benign
if that had been black folks we already
know that there would have been bodies
strewn about on the capitol grounds
from law enforcement's response and we
know that there would have been
americans who would have been applauding
that
and saying that those were our just
desserts for showing up at the capitol
to protest police violence so the
hypocrisy
is glaring but it's as american as apple
pie
but after trump the election of joe
biden
brought a renewed sense of optimism at
last
there was an acceptance from the highest
office in the land
that discrimination is embedded in
america's dna
the systemic racism is a stain on our
nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
the conviction of derek chauvin was a
landmark ruling
that could lead to a change in police
culture
and not just in the city where george
was murdered but across the whole
of the us we need people who are in a
better position
to value the rights and dignity and
humanity of the people that they've been
sworn to serve
and if they can't do that if they can't
do that
then punishment is the order of the day
for you
derek shoving should spend the rest of
his foul ass
life in prison that would be the best
training
that the remaining officers in
minneapolis could ever get
under existing laws chauvin could only
be tried in a minnesota state court
this means he was not eligible for the
severest punishment
that can be handed out by the u s
government
and there is now a demand for that to
change
if we had the correct set of laws
derek shobin's next trial should be in
federal court as a as a vice which is
what they've done with the ku klux klan
that's how they got rid of it
you go to federal court and you are
convicted at the federal level and you
go
into the federal pen that's what these
cops need to understand
you go in and the keys are thrown
away now with joe biden in the white
house
there is a possibility those demands
could become law
there's a federal bill that is named
after george that our family is working
to to get past
it's going gonna afford us those changes
that will
change the way police are interacting
with
people in general especially
black men the aim of the george floyd
bill
to bring about the severest penalties
for racist crimes
is welcome but many question why it has
taken america so long
we're glad that they are finally
deciding to step up to the plate
and bring these charges against these
officers but why did it take a public
lynching
in order for that to happen why isn't
the justice department
being routinely involved in these types
of incidences
and taking a more serious look at the
the police departments that are allowing
the levels of unchecked power that we've
seen
happening in these types of cases half a
century ago dr martin luther king
campaigned for a similar overhaul to the
u.s criminal justice system
but he also realized that racial
equality
was about more than just legal reform he
said that
america is going to have to have a
radical redistribution
to create opportunities for all people
the problem is we've not made enough
progress
he'd be greatly disappointed if he were
alive and where in terms of where we are
by now we should have resolved the issue
of race
we should have significantly reduced
poverty
and hopefully that would create the
condition for violence to be reduced
and today anger at the failure to bring
about such
transformation burns brightly on the
streets of minneapolis
are they going to come to the table and
start to get [ __ ] done
instead of giving us some band-aids over
some gaping wounds are they going to
acknowledge the systematic racism in
every walk of life whether it's
education economics
military social
what's it like in the neighborhood like
this
you know to be honest with you
everybody's looking for a way out to get
to bigger and better things that's what
it feels like to be a neighborhood like
this
now being a black man
hell yeah is dangerous in the
neighborhood like this because
on top of us having to deal with the
police it's a lot of
self-hatred that we have to deal with as
well
and that's not good at all you know it's
you know when you have helpless people
who have nothing they will be quick to
take
take everything from you because they
don't have anything to lose
dr martin luther king jr talked a lot
about
having to cash a check mark insufficient
funds
and the lack of ongoing economic
access to opportunity that black people
have experienced i mean when we look at
our
system of mass incarceration here in the
united states
we have five percent of the world's
population but 25 percent of its
prisoners
and we are number one in terms of our
rate of incarceration
roughly 40 percent of those who are
incarcerated are black
and the majority of people who are
incarcerated lived at or below the
poverty line
prior to their incarceration
george floyd grew up poor and lived poor
in the suburbs of two wealthy american
cities
environments that demeaned his humanity
and set him on a collision course with a
law enforcement system
that took his life his murderer's
conviction
means there is now some legal justice
for him and his family
but for millions of black americans the
days of equality
dignity and social justice seem as far
away as ever
we will always feel targeted we will
always feel
isolated we will always feel
disrespected
until they decide to start to respect us
and honor us as humans
right now we don't have that right now
we have
people in power and people in authority
positions who are not honoring the
respect
of humanity until they start to respect
humanity that's when we can start to get
some changes done
oh
i can't breathe
you're taking my life from me
i can't breathe
for me